we are being asked what is the smallest
this is a little typo here what is the
smallest possible sum of squares of two
numbers if their product is negative 16
so let's say that these two numbers are
x and y x and y so how could we define
the sum of the squares of the two
numbers so I'll just call that the sum
of the squares s4 sum of the squares and
it would just be equal to x squared plus
y squared and this is what we want to
minimize we want to minimize minimize s
now right now s is expressed as a
function of x and y we don't know how to
minimize with respect to two variables
so we have to get this in terms of only
one variable and lucky for us they give
us another piece of information their
product is negative 16 so x x times y is
equal to negative 16 so let's say we
wanted this this expression right over
here only in terms of X well then we
could solve we can figure out what Y is
in terms of X and then substitute so
let's do that right over here if we
divide both sides by X we get Y is equal
to negative 16 over X and so let's
replace our Y in this expression with
negative 16 over X so then we would get
our our sum of squares as a function of
X is going to be equal to x squared plus
y squared Y is negative 16 over X
negative 16 over X and then that's what
we will now square so this is equal to x
squared plus what is this 256 256 over x
squared or we could write that as 256
256 X to the negative 2 power that is
the sum of our squares that we now want
to minimize well to minimize this we
would want to look at the critical
points of this which is where the
derivative is either zero or undefined
and see whether those critical points
are possibly a minimum or a maximum
point they don't have to be but those
are the ones if we
have a minimum or maximum point they're
going to be one of the critical points
so let's take the derivative so the
derivative s Prime we do this in a
different color as prime of X I'll do it
right over here actually the derivative
s prime of X with respect to X is going
to be equal to 2x times negative 2 times
5 6 so 2 2 X plus 256 times negative 2
so that's minus 512 X to the negative 3
power x to the negative 3 power now this
is going to be undefined this is going
to be undefined when X is equal to 0 but
if X is equal to 0 then Y is undefined
so this whole thing breaks down so that
isn't a useful critical point x equals 0
so let's think about any other ones well
the its defined everywhere else so let's
think about where the derivative is
equal to 0 so when does this thing equal
0 so when does 2x minus 5 12 X to the
negative 3 equals 0 well we can add 5 12
X to the negative 3 to both sides so you
get 2x is equal to 512 X to the negative
third power we can multiply both sides
times X to the 3rd power multiply both
sides times X to the 3rd so all the X's
go away on the right hand side so you
get 2 X to the fourth is equal to 512 we
can divide both sides by 2 and you get X
to the fourth power is equal to 256 and
so what is the 4th root of 256 well we
could take the square root of both sides
just to help us here so let's see if we
take so it's going to be x squared is
going to be equal to 256 is 16 squared
so this is 16 this is going to be x
squared is equal to 16 or X is equal X
is equal to 4 now that's our only
critical point we have so that's
probably the x value that minimizes our
sum of squares right over here but let's
make sure it's a minimum value and to do
that we can just do our second
derivative test so let's figure out
let's take the second derivative
as prime prime of X and figure out if we
are concave upwards or downwards when X
is equal to four so s prime prime of X
is going to be equal to two and then we
have negative three times negative five
twelve so I'll just write that as plus 3
times 512 that's going to be 1500 and 36
is that right yeah 3 times 500 is 1500 3
times 12 is 36 X to the negative 4 power
so this thing is going to be and this
thing right over here is actually going
to be positive for any X this thing is
this thing is going to be positive for
any X X to the negative 4 if even if
it's a negative x value that's going to
be positive
everything else is positive this thing
is always positive so we are always in a
concave concave upwards situation
concave upwards means that our graph
might look something like that which I
don't want to draw a little squiggle it
might look something like that and you
see the reason why the second derivative
implies concave upwards the second
derivative positive means that our
derivative is is constantly increasing
so the derivative is constantly
increasing it's negative less negative
even less negative let me do it in a
different color
you see it's negative less negative even
less negative 0 positive more positive
so it's increasing over the entire place
so if you have a critical point where
the derivative is equal is equal to 0
so the slope is equal to 0 and it's
concave upwards you see pretty clearly
that we have minimized
we have minimized the function so what
is y going to be equal to we actually
don't even have to figure out what Y has
to be equal to in order to minimize the
sum of squares we could just put it back
into this but just for fun we see that Y
would be negative 16 over X so Y would
be equal to negative 4 and we could just
figure out now what our sum of squares
is ours minimum sum of squares is going
to be equal to
it's going to be equal to 4 squared
which is 16 plus negative 4 squared plus
another 16 which is equal to 32 now I
know some of you might be thinking hey I
could have done this without calculus I
could have just try
out numbers whose product is negative 16
and I probably would have tried out 4
and negative 4 in not too much time and
then I would have been able to maybe
figure out that it's lower than if I did
2 and negative 8 or negative 2 and 8 or
1 and 16 and that's true you probably
would have been able to do that but you
still wouldn't have been able to feel
good that that was a minimum value
because you wouldn't have tried out for
point 0 1 or 4 point 0 0 1 1 in fact you
couldn't have tried out all of the
possible values remember we didn't say
that this is only integers it just
happened to be that our values worked
out to be just worked out to be integers
in this situation you can imagine what
would happen if the problem wasn't if
their product is negative 16 but what if
their product is negative 17 or what if
their product is negative 16 point 5 or
what if their product was PI squared
then you wouldn't be able to try
everything else out and you would have
to resort to doing what we did in this
video